My name is John and this is Dreamflow
Tips, where we give evidence-based
prompting and AI coding tips. Now, you
may have heard the advice from an AI
influencer that after you ask your
coding agent to do something, you should
say something like, "If you're less than
95% confident you can complete this
task, ask clarifying questions until you
reach that confidence level." Now, this
advice is partially right and partially
wrong. And I know this because these
kinds of queries have been studied. So
in this video, I'm going to show you
those studies and based on those studies
give you the best recommendations for
improving your prompting for coding
agents.
The idea of instructing a large language
model to ask follow-up questions is a
significant improvement in prompt
engineering. The concept assumes that
every response from a model has an
implicit confidence value or the
question has a certain level of
ambiguity that typically goes
uncaptured. For instance, when you ask
the model to implement state management
for a screen, this request breaks down
into multiple subtasks and the model has
varying levels of confidence in the best
approach for each one. There's an
implicit ambiguity. The underlying
principle is that resolving ambiguity
before execution is more efficient and
reliable than attempting to generate a
solution from an underspecified prompt.
So let's start with the part of the
advice that's absolutely right. Asking
the model to ask clarifying questions.
In the 2023 paper titled large language
models should ask clarifying questions
to increase confidence in generated
code. makes a powerful argument for
this. The researchers observe that top
tier human software engineers
systematically ask questions to reduce
ambiguity before writing a single line
of code. The study proposes that LLMs
should do the same using a communicator
agent to interact with the user and
resolve uncertainties before a coder
agent generates the final program. This
communication first process directly
addresses the primary cause of errors in
AI generated code, unclear or incomplete
user requests. This idea was then tested
and validated in a 2025 study called
Curiosity by Design, an LLM based coding
assistant asking clarifying questions.
Researchers built an endto-end system
that first uses a classifier to detect
if a prompt is ambiguous. If it is, the
system doesn't generate code. Instead,
it uses a fine-tuned LLM to generate a
highquality clarification question. And
a user study confirmed a strong
preference for this interactive model
over traditional ones that simply
guesses the user's intent. Users rated
the questions as having a highly
significant, better precision and focus,
which ultimately led to more accurate
and helpful code. Okay, but now for the
part of the advice that's wrong,
stipulating a confidence value, like
95%.
This instruction is based on a flawed
premise, as shown in a 2025 study,
calibration and correctness of language
models for code. The researchers found
that an LLM's raw internal confidence is
a poor predictor of actual correctness.
In their tests, even when a model's
average token probability exceeded 90%,
so it was very sure its solution was
correct, the generated code only passed
unit tests 52% of the time. This severe
misalignment is known as the calibration
problem. The study concludes that an
LLM's self-reported confidence is not a
trustworthy signal out of the box.
Simply telling the model to act in a 95%
or 90% threshold is asking it to use a
metric it can't reliably measure on its
own. Okay. So what does all this mean
for your prompting? Well, let's look at
some before and after examples. Okay. So
for this first example, I wanted to give
it a complicated task. Not because this
is the kind of thing that you should do
with your agent. You shouldn't. But I
wanted to demonstrate this clarifying
ambiguity really clearly. So I grab a
screenshot of Verscell's deployments
dashboard. It's pretty complicated. Now,
of course, if you were building this out
using best practices, you would break it
down into each part of the UI and build
it step by step. But here, I just wanted
to oneshot it. So with this agent, I
just said create the attached UI. In the
second example, I said create the
attached UI. But before writing code,
analyze my request. If you have any
ambiguity in the best way to accomplish
this task, ask clarifying questions. Do
not proceed until I answer. And the
results are really fascinating for a
couple of reasons. So, if we look back
over here, it did a pretty good job. Of
course, we have uh the background color,
which wasn't correct. We have this
middle nav right here, which shouldn't
work like that. We've got some padding
issues. So, the visual fidelity may be
80% here. But the purpose of this
exercise isn't to see how close it can
get, but it's to look at the workflow.
So when we look down here and we go to
the bottom, we can see, let me go to the
end of this request, we can see that
this uses 6 and 1/2 credits. So quite a
lot of credits. But when we look over at
the other one where I asked it to ask
questions, we can see some interesting
things. So down here, before I proceed
with creating this UI, some clarifying
questions. So, first it asks if it
should use mock data or there's a
specific back-end service that it could
model the data on. It asks if we wanted
to implement functionality. It asks if
the navigation should be a tab
navigation or a standalone page. It asks
about responsiveness. And another
question about functionality. Now,
what's fascinating about this is that
when you ask this question, it discloses
what was implicit in the previous
example. that is there was some previous
ambiguities that in the other example
the model resolved by itself. Instead
here I'm the one making the decisions
and this is the ideal way to work with
AI agents. That is you're not
relinquishing all control. You're simply
using the AI agent as a multiplier for
you the developer. So you're still
planning and reviewing the generated
code but you offload a lot of the actual
writing of the code to the agent. But
you should still have a similar amount
of knowledge of the code base and its
architecture. The other fascinating
thing is that you can see this process
took only.3 credits. And when we look
down at the actual execution here, we
can see that it was 2.6 credits.
Significantly less than the credit usage
over here, almost three times as much.
And so resolving those ambiguities
allows the model to scope down because
it'll be less eager in its execution.
Now, this might just be the example for
here, but I did also find it fascinating
that the overall execution was much
closer to the screenshot in this
example. And I think this just has to do
with the execution budget. That is to
say, the model has internal metrics for
how long, how much it's going to work.
And if your prompt is clearer for the
model, it won't spend extra token usage
on things that it know you don't want,
which means there's more token usage for
things like visual fidelity. In the
previous example, it may have
substituted some of the visual design
for other things like functionality that
it assumed that it filled in that
ambiguity that I wanted to build out.
Now, of course, this isn't a real
example. Like I said before, the scope
of work that you want to offload to
agents should be very small. So, let's
look at a more real world example. In
this example, I have a shaden showcase
library right here. And I wanted to
implement a bookmarking or favorite
feature. So user can favorite it and
then come back later and see their
favorite components. So for this first
example, I didn't ask it to clarify
anything. And it did a good job. The
feature works. You can see I've
bookmarked one there. When I go to
favorites, I can see it there. It has a
routing correct. And that's great. And
when we look at the code, we can see if
we open up here, it implemented a
favorite service right here. And it's
pretty standard. Now once again when we
look at the token usage here it was 9.1
credits. That's quite a bit. When we
look at our other example I asked it to
implement the feature but I append this
same thing to my request. Make sure you
ask clarifying questions. So then it
asked about the scope and at first I
thought this was kind of a dumb question
cuz it said should users be able to
bookmark individual components for quick
access? But then I realized it was
asking this because my request is pretty
thread there. It's pretty minimal and
they wanted to and the model wanted to
make sure that it understood the
fundamental request and we're not even
into questions about implementation.
Then we get to questions about
implementation about persistence and
state. So should the bookmark components
persist across app sessions? I said yes.
It asked about where do you want them to
be displayed? How should the UX work and
any visual indicators? And once again
this clarifying question is very light
token usage. And when we go down to the
final execution here, we can see that
this was significantly less token usage
and it works in a similar way. So I've
harded these, I can go to the favorites,
I can view them there and the routing
works correctly and when we look at the
service, it's implemented. It works in
very similar ways. Okay, so to
summarize, first you should absolutely
instruct your coding agent to ask
clarifying questions to resolve
ambiguities before it writes code. This
approach is backed by multiple studies
showing improved outcomes. Second, you
should not ask it to rely on an internal
confidence score like 95% as research
shows it's not a reliable metric for
code correctness. Okay, so that's it for
Dreamflow Tips. I'm John and I'll see
you in the next video.